[PEPPY MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Looking to
build a SaaS solution?
Look no further.
With Google Cloud,
you can build smarter
SaaS solutions with cutting-edge
AI and machine learning
technology.
Build and deploy a SaaS
solution faster and with greater
flexibility thanks to advanced
continuous integration
and delivery tools.
Build to scale and meet your
growing data and traffic
demands.
Build your business
and boost sales
by listing your product in
Google Cloud marketplaces,
and join the Google
Cloud Partner Advantage.
Build on the same infrastructure
that serves billions of users.
Build on the platform
made for SaaS.
Build on Google Cloud.